an emergency evacuation on the Greek
island of Rhodes
with little advanced warning thousands
of holiday makers and residents rushed
to escape the out of control wildfires
nearby
private boats join the Greek Coast Guard
rescuing people from beaches on the
Southeastern part of the island the
Greek army also helped get people to
safety
firefighters battle forest fires across
Greece every summer but this year the
fires have been exacerbated by an
intense heat wave
they've also been wildfires outside
Athens at least a hundred homes have
been destroyed in lutraki 80 kilometers
west of the capital risula renieri
surveys the damage to her home
everything was destroyed we have
suffered too much damage too much my
husband has suffered a lot I fear
something might happen to him but I'm
also in a miserable state
but there is no respite Greece is
bracing for more intense Heat this
weekend with meteorologists warning that
temperatures could reach 45 degrees
Celsius Victoria gatenby Al Jazeera